and it's a lot of it's more nba players
that's going through ramadan
that y'all know for every piece of jury
you know i've dated some of the most
you know famous and beautiful women you
know and all of that stuff you know
without a law it means nothing without
prayer it means nothing and it's
it's a real empty feeling since you
mentioned uh sneaker
i i want to get your thoughts on
something little knives x
and i have good news and bad news
good news maybe that the old town road
performer
is getting a lot of attention so irving
kyrie irving
that's his name right grateful always to
allow god for allowing me to come out
here
so i'm just grateful people say that to
me all my lives and in my comments like
they think they're going to offend me
like they'll say
brother you should love jesus and i'm
like i do love jesus i'm muslim this
could be my last ramadan this could be
your last ramadan this could be eddie's
last ramadan
let's take advantage of every single
salah let's take advantage of every
single duo
and we will need the breakfast club and
we got the dean's show
[Applause]
how you guys doing we got our next guest
coming up
g-unit philly let's win hustler starve
aka tone trump giving shahada's out in
philly
how are you doing my brother i humbled
him all as well i'm glad to be here
did we hit that right let's win hustle
or starve is that you
some of that stuff is me a lot of that
stuff is old you know i can always tell
when somebody did they wikipedia
so so some of that stuff you said in the
beginning is old but it's all a part of
my story so i can't you know
i can't deny it but we want a bigger and
better things you know by the permission
of the law so right now it's just the
top i
the prettiest the smartest the fly is
donald trump the big dime
muslim down family and i'm i'm honored
to be here with you today brother
i like that i like that we all have a
past we have some
history let's go into a little bit of
your history
and what brought you to where you are
today that you're actually thinking a
lot different
um best way i can answer that question
is um
about uh about seven years ago
you know the birth of my son alim sameer
um
his mother had some complications during
delivery
and she had a fever so they started to
like try to rush deliver the baby
um i didn't have a lot of experience i
was very very scared
and um i had went outside the hospital
room and i prayed and i just
you know i was asking the law because
i've always i've always been aware of
allah
i've always been aware of islam my
father you know and my uncle brought
islam to our family before i was born so
i've always had
knowledge of islam but i didn't always
you know follow the sunnah and
follow the uh you know the the the
rights and rules of being a you know
a praying and believing muslims so i had
knowledge but i was living a life that
wasn't
you know conducive we're calling myself
a muslim so long story short i made a
prayer and i basically asked the lord
you know if you would protect my child
if you would bless my child to come out
of this
you know i would change my life i would
do things differently i would you know
just
things that i think a lot of us do when
we when our back is totally against the
wall
especially people who don't pray
normally you usually pray when
you know the chips are down and that's
what i did and allah answered my prayers
my son was a thousand percent healthy
he's actually
about 10 feet away from me right now
playing on his ipad on charlotte
so i kept my part of the promise you
know to strive to live better
and as i you know it started with
different steps a good friend of mine
named kasib had invited me to a friday
prayer one day
and it started with me going one week to
me going every week you know another
brother muhammad was inviting me out i
always forget to mention them when i
tell the story
so may it all be please and reward both
of them because they play a big part in
my journey
they both kind of just like the same way
people would hit me up to go to clubs or
to hang on the block
these two particular brothers would hit
me up on fridays you know what we
praying at
you know and it's different when you
know brothers you love and respect put
that on you because it's like you know
you don't want to say
i ain't praying this week or i ain't
going nowhere you know i had to have an
answer so i'm like you know i'm going to
never will i'm going to mooch though i'm
going to pray at this masjid
and it started to feed my soul in a way
that i was realizing how much i needed
to pray consistently how much i needed
this word
and it was all making you know when i
was young and i was hearing about islam
sometimes it
it didn't resonate with me but now
everything that you man was saying every
cook bars felt so personal like he was
talking to me or about me
and um i developed a personal
relationship with the dean that um
i feel like as i began to pray even more
and to read and read even more
that i really felt my true purpose and
calling and um i thank a lot every
single day i wake up for that so that's
how i got to the point i am now
it started with just different things
different efforts i started with the
prayer for my son
fast forward to about three years ago i
went to the uh i went to umrah
and i did that prayer over again this
time at the kaaba asking allah in a
different way just to
you know replace all the things i'm
doing haram with halal
and make it where i can maintain a
lifestyle that i've that i'll be honest
that i still love there's a lot of
things that i
that i struggle with that i shouldn't
love anymore that i still have a
have a love for eddie so i some people
like to pretend like you know when they
take shahada you know
you get a new slate and now you're this
new person and i'm humbly that
some of the things from this dunya is
hard to let go of for others
you know everybody has different you
know jihads and different things they
deal with
and for me some of the things that i
attach myself to
are very transparent because of the fact
what i do for a living i'm a rapper i'm
an influencer i'm an actor so people see
me
and um you know you know as a muslim
we're supposed to conceal our sins
and then my business is hard to do that
so you know sometimes that's
that's the constant contradiction but to
totally answer your question
those different trials in my life
starting with my son the birth of my son
were things that really made me um you
know step my game up and
that's how you got the the man the
muslim and the dying that you're talking
to today martial
mashallah so you have a a big muslim
community in philly is that right
very big very big mashola um
philadelphia i like to say it's the
biggest uh
african-american muslim community in
america
and you know and in north america
anywhere i've
you know i've been blessed by a lot of
travel everywhere and i've never been
anywhere where i felt the presence of uh
you know sure slam and you know muslims
and you know seeing hijabs and the cobs
and
you know those and coofies in the same
manner that you see here in philadelphia
is the thing i'm most proud about this
city it's a lot of things in this city
right now that
aren't to be very proud of but you know
the the the place
you know being so you know conducive for
being muslim you know
you know so many places to pray so many
places to eat halal
is something that i don't take for
granted i'm very grateful of you know
being here in philadelphia in my show
i've never been to philly but if i come
down you maybe take me to what's this
place called eats by dre get some crab
cakes
oh he gonna lie that shout out i'm
definitely gonna get you some crab cakes
from east by drake martial
i'm gonna take you to yo when you come
to philly you want and just so you know
for those listening who don't know
we've even coined philly philistine
which is um a lot of times when people
see hear me or
see hear me say that they think i'm
talking about our brothers and sisters
in palestine who i love
but um we renamed the you know the stand
when you hear afghanistan and uh
palestinians and uh pakistan the
standards land up
so we took it for lambda philly and you
know being such a muslim city
um you know some people ride through
philly and they feel like they're in a
muslim country sometimes bro you see so
many muslims
so it's a beautiful thing do you think
it's
it's like a because you mentioned
something now it's a jihad every day i
struggle every day
it's you know but for somebody who's
experienced for people who've kind of
just had most of what you can have in
the dunya
and now you've tasted it right you've
tasted the other side
you taste the sweetness of iman that's
what brought you to where you are
but now fighting like you said every day
you know the temptations that are out
there and what do you tell people
who are now striving to kind of go
towards that life that you're trying to
fight against falling back you know
people
you know on the fence sometimes you know
and you see people they come over they
they experience the iman the sweetness
of salah of prayer of connection with
their creator
but then some people you know they end
up falling back
because of that struggle that constant
jihad that constant war that we're with
with the satanic forces
you think it's hard it's it's harder
because you've experienced most of
most of the delights of this life it's
more of a challenge where other people
they
they haven't you know gone toward or
experienced some of the
the many things that you've experienced
i think it may be more of a challenge
for some but i think for me it's more of
a blessing because
i think because of some of the you know
the success and failure i've had in the
dunya and
the worldly things i've seen it at so
many levels bro i've been around you
know i've worked with some of the most
famous people in the world
i've been around some very miserable
people who have a lot of things in his
worldly life to let me know how much
that that stuff doesn't really mean you
know i've i've drove
every single car you could think of you
know i i i've had some you know
i've wore every piece of jury you know
i've dated some of the most you know
famous and beautiful women you know and
all that stuff you know without a law it
means nothing without prayer it means
nothing and it's it's a real empty
feeling
when you realize that you work so hard
and you you think you want certain
things until you get them
and then when you get them you realize
they really don't mean anything and they
really don't matter
and that's why you see uh you know
people struggling with mental health and
a lot of times you know
you see people we think have everything
you know they commit suicide because you
know the things that we
redeem as everything aren't really
anything and that's what we struggle
with in this world and
and it's easy to say sometimes more than
to do but um
i'm living proof man like i've seen it
all man like i've seen it all on every
level
you know growing up one you know i
wanted fame i wanted money i wanted the
music
world so bad and as those things started
to come and you know some of the things
they cut and another thing about haram
money
it doesn't last it doesn't sustain you
know and
and you can have you know we've seen
that so many times look how many people
you've seen
they say was worth 50 million dollars
and then they and then they
poor and they homeless you know and
people say man i would never let that
happen to me you can never say never
because
for one everything's written by a law
and for two you think those people that
lost all that money thought they were
going to lose it no everybody's not just
dumb everybody's not just blowing their
money it's it's the fact that you're
trying to do this and live this life
when you try to do this without god
it's not going to work i don't care who
you are and even when we think it works
in this worldly life we look at some
celebrities and you may think
you know um i hate to always use them as
example but i always like to use the
kardashians as an example because
people see them with all that money and
all that fame
and they're always looking for something
else you know from from every member of
the family like you know they're
they're you know reconstructing the way
god made them look
you know the the head of their household
tried to turn himself into a female for
crying all out with all that money in
that fame
he wasn't happy with being mean you know
what i mean so i
i i like to use that for example
especially when i'm talking to younger
people they got every
you know um kanye west is over there
they just named him a billionaire does
anybody think he looks happy
does anybody think he looks like he you
know do you see a door in his face when
you see him
no you know that darkness and that
sadness that you're saying
that's this dunya that's the shaytan
despite all that money despite that
beautiful wife this fight this is a guy
who
who his name is on the back of a sneaker
that
ninety percent of pop culture either are
wearing or want to wear and he's
miserable
so that's the perfect example i can give
you since you men since you mentioned uh
sneaker
i i want to get your thoughts on
something little knives eggs
and i have good news and bad news
good news maybe that the old town road
performer
with the launch of a pair of sneakers
and both
headlines blood sneakers lil na's x's
collaboration
art collective mischief were released
the same day as the video
the 666 pair of sneakers are black with
red trim
and feature gold pentagrams inverted
crosses
as well as human blood inside the soul
the shoes which are modified nikes are
you're the one that mentioned sneakers
so i want to get your
your reaction to that 21 year old rapper
so for everybody that hears that that
means ten years ago which isn't that
long ago that kid was in seventh grade
eighth grade maybe so he's a kid he's a
baby
but the people at columbia records the
label he signed to
the people at nike the billion-dollar
corporation that
creates that sneaker the people at
whatever company that did the collab
they all should be held accountable for
what they're pushing out
because they're they're they're aiming
at for our children to see it
and it's and it's promoting you know
satanic rituals is promoting
homosexuality
it's promoting cross-dressing and these
are all things that
i don't think is fair that is being
pushed by such powerful corporations
when you talk about
colombia records nike uh
you know and these these are giants so i
think it's sad i think it's pure evil
and i pray allah protects my children
and all children from you know entities
like this
and this is why i feel like it's so
important when people criticize
you know the muslim entertainers and
influencers doing you know content and
creating things
i understand we have to be mindful of
the way we represent islam but at the
same time we
also have to you know we have to you
know we living in 2021 where these kids
got these phones in their hand and it's
like
i'd rather my kid be looking at you know
any of the muslim influence or
entertainers
all day over watching uh the kid you
just played on the screen i don't even
like saying none of their names but the
kitty
he just played on the screen so what
what do you uh when you see the youth
where do you begin
when you see them striving to emulate to
kind of do
you know live that life that you were
living to be around you know to to be a
star
you know uh where do you start where do
you begin with what do you what do you
tell them i think the start is listening
to them
and then i listen to them and then i
give them real life perspective
so i can tell them things that i went
through i could tell them things that i
experienced and
also letting them see me be successful
without doing those things
you know if the kids in my neighborhood
equate me driving a nice car and doing
different things with me
dealing with drugs and stuff like that
they believe that comes with it but if
these kids see me out here pushing uh
the power of prayer and see me talking
about waking up every day for fajr and
talk about tahiti classes and arabic
classes
and then doing great things um they'll
equate that with that as well inshallah
and i think that's one of the big things
for them to see us you know i do things
intentionally i did a meet and greet
and i make sure that when the young
muslim brothers that came out i met a
young brother named tariq
and you know he comes up to me and i
want to be like you big i and the first
thing i saw is man and start with that
fudge of prayer
and when i say that to him and he looks
over and we got a ferrari in the corner
and we got a you know a vintage sob on
the corner and a g5
binge wagon and all these different
things that he's only seen rappers and
drug dealers had
and he see his muslim elders having
these things and knowing that we can be
successful
and seeing us bridge the gap you know at
this particular uh meet and greet
i had uh mufti rafiq out there so i got
a movie out there on the same corner
with you know
ex-gang leaders and guys who just came
home from prison and just bridging the
gap so
the young brothers can also see us all
unified and i have all this separatism
or you know you people
oh what kind of muslim is he where is he
from and this race over here and this
type of muslim over here no how about we
all love the law we all acknowledge who
was last in the
beloved prophet is and we all come
together and not follow any entertainers
not follow
each other we follow the sooner and we
follow one for our brother and sister we
want for ourselves
and i feel like when the youth see that
at a successful level
eddie i think we'll see a lot of change
i think people are busy yelling at these
kids and telling them what they can't do
and tell them
what not to do and nobody's giving them
any alternatives nobody's showing them
how to make any real halal money
you tell these kids don't do anything
haram but then the only way you tell
they can make halal money is
stuff that they got to go to school for
for 50 years come out of school and a
whole bunch of debt
and kids now are wise enough kids now
are saying hey man people are going to
college
graduating college and working for high
school dropouts
so it's like people are smart enough now
so we have to show them
those alternatives whether it be through
our faith starting with our faith and
then starting with our own personal
experiences
and that's what the donald trump
movement the muslim down moving is all
about it's reality
it's not no fake stuff it's not no
facade this is reality
you know i can't sit here and tell these
kids about you know
stopping the violence without telling my
true story i've been shot before
i've allegedly shot people before so
it's like i got to tell these kids my
truth
what was going through my mind what
consequence our faces
how much being shot hurts not just
physically but mentally
how much it hurts your family your
mother having to get that phone call
and just being real with them and let
them know how much it's much funner
to be doing things the right way and
flying around the world business class
and
you know eating great food and meeting
great people and collabing with other
great believers and
i just want to show them that lifestyle
and showing that you know it's a way
that you can do it
and see this and you know without you
know you can get fame being a grady man
or a great scholar or student of
knowledge
you can get fame being a scientist you
can get fame being a computer
you know computer tech guys so many
things you can do to get you know fame
or notoriety as well as money and for
loose so it's like you just got to be
smart about it
and you got to pray on it with purpose
and that's the law to guide your
intentions and guide your education and
that feel
and then just do what i do man you know
tunnel vision don't look don't worry
about what nobody's saying just work
every day
and pray every day like it's your last i
see you really like uh
you know taking that responsibility of
sharing the message you know the purpose
of life with the people doing dawah like
every
muslim should be striving to do and what
do you like
to talk about in what direction do you
take when you have uh
people who have this love for jesus
and then obviously it's an article of
faith in islam to believe and love jesus
one of the mightiest messengers of god
so how do you take that conversation
when jesus comes up
in your conversation so i think the
first thing is like what you said you
know is when we speak about the prophet
he says
peace and must be upon him is mainly
letting them know how much we love them
and i think that's the biggest
misconception people believe because we
don't pray to jesus that somehow we
don't like him or we hate him
so i feel like the main thing is to show
the regard that we speak of his name and
to show you know how much we love him so
no we love jesus like it's like people
say that to me all my lives and in my
comments like they think they're going
to offend me like they'll say
brother you should love jesus and i'm
like i do love jesus i'm muslim
you know i love i love all of allah's
creation including you know the prophet
so uh that's my main thing like i i
think the main thing is like getting
that stereotype out the way because
i'm glad you said that because that's a
conversation i pretty much have every
time someone takes shahadah
so you know and and masha'allah my
movement you know the other day we did
uh we did a
toy uh give back and uh we had two
brothers take shahada mashaallah and one
of the brothers was a strong you know
brother coming from you know the
christian faith and that was his thing
you know
what about my love for jesus and moved
in with thee and i'm like yo bro you
don't gotta
now hate jesus you know you don't have
to hate anybody or anything
and i think when we start to give him
that dowel and i think that's why
one of the most important things we need
to be pushing to is just having you know
creating tahiti classes and being able
to show people true understanding of
of the dean you know and true
understanding of top one and the
different things because a lot of times
you hand somebody a canaan a prayer rug
and you say you know figure it out and
that's not fair to them
it's not fair to this beautiful and
perfect religion islam
and that's what people love about when
you talk about tohit that pure
monotheism
when we we talk about you know the deep
love of jesus that we worship like jesus
we greet like jesus peace be
upon you this is how he greeted he
prayed like we pray because he was a
muslim he submitted to the will of the
creator not the creation
even in the pictures that they post that
they proclaim to be jesus which i don't
you know you know i don't
necessarily prescribe to obviously that
picture that they push around looks like
that would be a muslim i mean in today's
time i mean this guy has a huge beard
he has a skin of bronze and he's wearing
a soap it sounds like either it sounds
like he's either a light-skinned black
dude or
you know you know what i'm hearing like
black black muslim or muslim to me just
by
his appearance that that they push out
by the way not that we're pushing out
even even what they had portrayed what
they push out of his blessed
mother who we love who there's a chapter
named after her in the quran
she's in in hijab right is that amazing
i use examples like that like i make it
practical for him like you know i mean
i may even now that we said this i may
start asking dudes like
let me see a picture of the jesus you
speak of and then ask them
if you had to bet if you didn't know who
that was and somebody said is he a
muslim
a christian or a jew for example i think
not ten out of ten if not nine out of
ten would say yes that's the aki that's
one of us
i think that's one way we can approach
it in charlotte
can we get you to talk about that on the
breast uh breakfast club
have you ever been on the breakfast club
in charlotte i should be doing a
breakfast club next month so
you heard it no that that popular show
the breakfast club is it where they get
different entertainers i should be doing
it next month oh yeah
yeah one thing about me because my
project dropped in june so we want to
schedule to run my project
the thing about me eddie is you don't
have to worry about me man
any microphone in front of me man islam
is going to come up
possible to interview donald trump you
can't interview me and not bring it up
you know i'm wearing some crowd on my
sleeve so
it's a lot of muslim artists that can
sit down with people like the breakfast
club
and they genuinely might not even know
that person's muslim you don't sit down
with me and not bring up something about
islam and i'm proud of that so they'll
definitely
we'll be definitely talking about those
five prayers we'll definitely be talking
about
you know you know the way islam changed
and saved my life
so i'm gonna do that on any platform and
if you don't see it trust me to edit it
out
and that'll be a problem because i'm not
there's no platform i went i was born
many times to maybe you know in so many
words to turn down
you know my my my broadness and my
unapologetic about my love for my faith
and i've never followed those orders
i've even done it more since they told
me to kind of tone it down i've turned
it up even more on my shoulder
i like that i like that unapologetically
one who has surrendered and submitted to
the creator that happens
that's what a muslim is and that's what
islam is to
do that action and this is something
that we should be proud of and this
hearing you seeing you hopefully
inshallah the youth and muslims can get
inspired
that they can go ahead like this you
actually were so excited about it
sharing that you shared it with
the person we're going to get your
reaction to this he's now in a masjid
and you you are a great uh influence in
sharing the message with this individual
four
[Music]
[Music]
out with to not be shy you see now he's
praying on the court now
and um this time it's time
it is time for especially guys
in that light to stop to feel like they
have to be something that they're not
i know and that's what kylie said you
know if i want to pray
if i want to if i want to praise allah
in front of the world
i should be able to do that without
offending anyone and
we're at the point now where we don't
care who
you know i'm saying that's where we're
at now that's why we all that's why most
of the players
and there's a lot of it's more than
being players that's going through
ramadan that y'all hope that y'all know
it's like eight or nine right now
and uh it's time it's time what are your
comments on that i'm
just so proud of him man i'm so proud of
him i'm so proud of
his message his movement i love that
brother man as you've seen you seen the
difference in my reaction from when you
played the first clip
to the second clip right that's it so
that's somebody uh you know i call him
aki five you know i mean
stack five stephen jackson man our
brother in faith
you know he was my brother before he was
a muslim and you know him taking shahada
him saying the beautiful words
you know layla allah made my my my my
twin brother my closest brother i love
him to death i love him
words can't express the love and respect
and honor i have for him and
you know he has a lot on him eddie like
you know he was already thrust into a
position of leadership for the civil
rights movement the biggest civil rights
movement ever people got to understand
what went on with george floyd the way
the world wasn't paying attention to
that that's never happened in the
history of
ever like even when you know our great
leaders like you know malcolm x and dr
martin luther king muhammad
ali and you know marcus garvey and i can
go on and on and
imam uh jamel jamil al-amin and these
different leaders
they didn't have the power of social
media to connect these different world
like when we were coming up when
something would happen to
us we didn't know that people all the
way in let's just say yemen could feel
our pain
and now because of social media we know
that and uh
aki five stephen jackson's been thrust
into a position of leadership he didn't
sign up for that
and even after he took shahada i've
never seen someone
you know revert to islam and just hit
the ground running with the type you
know you just showed a video of him
speaking in the mosque that brother's a
brand new muslim and he's already you
know garnering that
that love respect and attention and i'm
just honored to call him a brother i ask
the lord to continue to guide him and
protect him and
he is man he different bro like you know
he's he's just a special special human
being and i love him
and like i said i'm proud that he's with
us and i'm proud that you know we're
with him and
we're just getting started we got it we
got a tour we're working on right now
uh to announce real soon inshallah me
and him a top ah
big big don speaking tour that will be
giving darwin as well as doing some
different things and workshops and
show also be on the lookout for that and
um like i said i'm just proud to call
him my brother i love him you know
what's up with us
so a lot of people don't know that you
are actually there in the masjid with
him
you helped now we were saying this term
shahada i mean for the
not yet muslims who are out there
hearing this for a first time this is
basically declaring what's in your very
nature there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator that heavens and
earth
god almighty allah and then muhammad
just like jesus was the messenger
uh the final messenger so that's the
shahada and you were you were
someone who helped facilitate that you
were described that moment like what how
it led up to that
and just in brief and then you're in the
masjid together when he took his
shahadah
for those people that don't know the
story um well you know first of all it
was an honor
um every day your phone don't ring with
an nba world champion you know calling
you perry i don't care who you are let
alone
calling you for something so beautiful
so he had uh i want to say he probably
dm'd me first and
then we got on the phone and it was like
let's just say it was like a monday and
he was like
hey bro man i've been you know reading
up i've been studying man i feel like a
law is calling me
i want to take my shahada and and i want
it i want to do it i want to take it
with you
and um i that moment's priceless man
like i got chills man i was so excited
and i'm just like i'm like when
and you know and i'm like yo bro wait i
would love to do that man sean went and
he was like yo man i'm gonna try to come
like tomorrow
like this is like so here came like like
that wednesday man and um
i had reached out to um imam um hameed
and um
a young imam in my city who we work with
the muslim-bound family we work with
hand-in-hand because
he gives dawa out in a practical way you
know he studied in medina and he's very
knowledgeable student knowledge but he
also
is very practical when educating you
know the newer muslims which i thought
would be great
and um the brother flew in like a no
longer than
a day and a half two days later and and
the rest was amazing the red the rest
was something that was so beautiful and
uh
i'll tell you this eddie i'll sum it up
for you like this stephen jackson is
somebody who
got drafted you know went to the nba
right out of high school was a high
school all-american played
with kobe bryant nba world champion
played with hall of famers all these
great things
and he looked at me that day and said he
brought us the greatest day of my life
signed multi-main other contracts so you
know this isn't a guy who's lived some
boring life he's done some amazing great
things
and he was able to acknowledge that this
is the greatest you know moment of his
life martial
we heard a mention kyrie irving grateful
always to allow god for allowing me to
come out here
so i'm just grateful see a lot of people
have questions
but yeah i am taking part in ramadan
with a lot of my brothers and sisters
my muslim brothers sisters and it's been
an adjustment
that's really what i can say just being
committed
to my service to god allah and then
continuing on um
with whatever i'm guided with so you
know just happy to
to be part of my my community and doing
the right things
so fasting is definitely part of it
obviously if you know anything about the
muslim
community um but yeah i'm just just
really
blessed and grateful to to be taken
apart
so tell us about kyrie so he's people
are wondering is he muslim is he not but
it's official he is muslim he's fasting
and what do you know the background of
what led to him accepting
honestly eddie i have never heard him
say he's muslim i've heard him say he's
participating in ramadan
i've heard him say some different things
but i haven't heard him i wasn't there
when he uh took shahada
i haven't seen any any muslims i know
say they've seen or heard that so
i'm holding back on that for now but i
asked the law to guide him i think it'll
be great for the dean it'd be great for
kyrie first of all
yeah and i think it'll be great for you
know young black black boys and young
black muslim boys and
you know young boys period young arabs
will be inspired because this is
somebody they look up to anyway
so i ask a lot to guide him to the
correct path i don't want to speak too
much on that because i don't know much
about it i do know that stack loves him
and
stack is a mentor for him so i'll have
to check in with stack for that but the
last i
last i've known i'm not just going to
say somebody i don't but you know people
people believe everything they see on
social media
um i wish they believed in the law as
quick as they believed social media
means but uh
inshallah that day is coming
he also mentioned uh that there are a
lot there was like nine or there was a
a bunch of nba players that are uh
fasting they're muslim they're coming
that he's having an influence over what
what
uh do you know do you know about this
yeah um i know of a few players i know
jaylen brown from the boston celtics
martial law his uncle is
actually my manager so i know he um he's
participating in it
at least as fasting um i i'd like to be
careful with that because even when
people say like non-muslims are fasting
it's like
it's to me it's no fasting without
praying eddie so yeah yes you know
my show like so it's like you know like
my man who's a great teacher one
i remember one year he had said he said
if you know you're fast and you know if
you call yourself faster without praying
you're just starving yourself
so i understand that the non-muslims
like to show us respect but i don't want
to speak on nobody whether a celebrity
or not
because just because you're not eating
or just because you know some muslims
you know i want to be respectful
but at the same time i also want to be
respectful to to the fasting muslims
as well and i don't know just because
you don't eat it doesn't make you you
know
you're not observing ramadan because
there's so much more to that you know
from
from the reciting from us you know
fasting not just from food but fasting
from
our tempers and different desires and
different things like that so it's just
so much to it so
i do i've heard probably with the same
much as you heard
but i've just been focused on you know i
don't i don't focus on you know
millionaire basketball players bro
i focus on these little babies in the
ghetto who who are being murdered every
day you know
and that's been my mission and my focus
and my purpose so
i don't be knowing too much about them
guys but i pray a lot of guys tomorrow
to uh true islam and uh
and inshallah that happens but in the
meantime we got so many babies to focus
on so many kids to focus on
um we just did an initiative with the
prisoners they need us far more than uh
kyrie irving make 40 million a year he
got a bunch of people he can call
i got to be on i got to be in the ground
roots and i got to be in the streets
helping these people that need me today
and that's what i'm doing marshall yeah
you think that
because people in you mentioned prison
now do you think now
because when people are participating
obviously in the rat race of life so
many distractions especially if you got
that type of money those
those kind of uh the bling bling as they
call it uh
get bigger when the money get bigger
yeah distractions get bigger when the
money gets bigger but if you're
in is that one of the reasons why in the
prisons islam
is the along with outside the prison but
particularly here in prison is
when people are now confined and they
got a chance to think what's the purpose
of life why am i here why
being created they look at the evidence
of islam now and they're forced to
contemplate and to think
you know do you think this is why now in
in the prisons
so many people are accepting islam i
think i think it's deeper than that but
i i'm sure that plays a part but i think
it's deeper than that i mean i i truly
believe the law brings us back to the
place we pray the most so you have to be
careful about that
a lot of brothers get the prisoner man
you know you know in the hood they call
it you know
he on his dean you're on his dna praying
hard you see brothers come out of prison
they got you know big big prayer marks
on their forehead because they just
bumping their head on that
on that concrete in the behind behind
that g wall but um
i can't really speak you know from an
islamic standpoint i can't speak on why
from a personal standpoint you know i
want to be respectful to my brothers
that's locked up and my brothers
because a lot of times people feel like
they start trying to shame people who
take shahada in prison and i don't want
to
say anything that sounds anything like
that all i say is only a law can make
you muslim so when people take you out
in prison
at him that and um you know i you know
that's the one good thing about prison
that you know people are discovering the
beauty of islam
and i think a lot of times it's just the
influence like when you go somewhere bro
and people want to be like the dudes
that's running things and you know
sad to say but the prisons are ran
normally by the muslims so if you're 17
16 years old you're an adult prison all
the guys you look up to all the guys
that everybody fear all the guy that
people respect all the guys that the
guards talk too nice
normally are muslims so people get
attracted to wanting to be muslim and
the thing about prison is
the brothers in the prison that got 35
40 years in they're not going to let you
play with this dean you can't just have
a big beard
and some some cut off pants and think
you're a muslim no they're going to quiz
you they're going to question you on
your prayers they're going to question
you on different things
and and to educate you as well but just
know you're going to be pressed about
that
a few more questions before we conclude
tell us so let's take it back for our
phone my phone just gave me a thing
saying this great die so
but i'm but but we're good right now all
right all right couple more questions so
let's take it back
for the for the irvings you know the nba
players are
from just the young boys young adults
who are tuning in
and now before some who are you know
trying to sympathize with muslims you
know
and they're doing the ramadan but you
said even before that the prayer
but let's take it even before that now
acknowledging that there's only one and
only one creator of the heavens and
earth the shahada
go ahead if somebody's already they've
been looking into islam you know the
articles of faith
they're like okay i agree with that the
five pillars of this i agree with that
tahoe the pure monotheism what it starts
with and muhammad being the last and
final master
how would you go ahead and explain the
shahada for somebody out there who's
like okay
now i'm ready i want to become a muslim
i probably explain it the same way that
you know your favorite shake your
favorite scholar your favorite you know
i just do it in a way that i speak the
language of my people so i try to break
it down so if you was to watch a video
of any you know imam and
the way they would probably talk about
their love for islam our love is
probably
similar but the way i explain it is just
different so the main thing i do eddie
is i give life experiences
i let them know in the most convincing
voice the most passionate way
that islam saved my life and when i let
them know that
you know i'm living proof man people
have seen my walk people have seen my
journey so i don't really have to
oversell it man people see especially in
my neighborhood
and then now even globally because
people have seen my struggles on the
internet there's people on the internet
that have seen me
get into fights and beasts there's
people on the internet that see me get
arrested
there's people on the internet that's
seeing people close to me get arrested
for everything from murder
to selling drugs to everything so the
things that i've been affiliated with
you know throughout my career in my life
and you know just being from where i'm
from
you know all these different trials and
tribulations so when people see that and
then they see where i'm at now
bro that's so much of a testimony you
know one day uh
the great scholar dr sherman jackson
said to me one day he spoke about me
just being in the masjid
that being a former dollar so for people
you know when i walk into manchester and
everybody's staring at my tattoos and
stuff like that i can take offense to
that
or i can use that for opportunity to
just give dawah or they may just receive
dollars just by looking at me because
if you're somebody who's trying to be
holier than thou and you think you're so
perfect but you miss the future lots
and you look over and see it right you
see a black muslim with
a hundred tattoos on it he's in
instahood and he's praying and praying
that's gonna make you feel away so we
inspire even those who don't like us and
love us and we try to do it with real
life and real practice
when i talk about the religion you know
my uncle used to tell me you don't have
to wear your religion
on your sleeve you have to wear it on
your heart i chose to wear it on both
and it's been it's been it's been it's
been trials for that and it's been
successes for that
and how did he laugh for it all the good
and the bad so the main thing i do bro
is i break it down in a language
you know i talk to them in a way they
can understand there's certain ways i'm
talking in certain words i'm using in
this interview
that i'm not going to use with a 15 year
old on 54th street i'm just not and um
mashaallah that's one of the reasons i
think i have success because i speak the
language of the people
which are beloved prophet peace and
blessed to be upon him always it was
very very very important
dressing and speaking the language of
people you know you serve
and i know who i serve
all right so with that said brother any
uh final words uh is ramadan
for the people out there for the muslims
out there for the night yet muslims
what uh what message you want to end
with for those that aren't muslim i just
want to say that i pray allah guides you
to the truth and and
to the one you know the oneness of the
law and i ask the law to guide you to
islam
islam and keep you on the correct path
for those that are muslim
keep praying keep striving keep working
i'm living proof of the law's mercy
i'm living proof of my mother's prayers
and you you know
to those that are watching just keep
just keep keep praying
keep pushing keep believing love the law
love yourself
love humanity and um right now in these
last you know
you know i don't know when they're gonna
hear this but we right now we're living
within the last 10 days
there's so many people who didn't know
last year was gonna be the last ramadan
this could be my last ramadan this could
be your last ramadan this could be
eddie's last ramadan
let's take advantage of every single
salah let's take advantage
of every single duo let's make
intentions to go to mecca and medina
let's make intentions to do better in
our communities
less than if you're not married make
intentions to get married if you come
from a non-muslim family
make sure they know how to properly bear
you get your affairs in order
this is the last few days of ramadan
make it count because if this
is your last round think about how you
prepared for the last day of school
or the last day of work or whatever it
may have been
this could be your last ramadan
you know may allah have mercy on us all
i ask all those that are watching and
listening if you're able to watch the
dean show
you're blessed you either have a phone
or a computer pray for those with less
pray for the believers that are behind
the bars malcolm x was in prison before
you guys all love him now
the next malcolm x may be in prison
right now make dua for that person
and i'm out man the biggest act the top
the biggest guy
they never thought they had seen it they
never thought they'd
i was hoping you said something i don't
know why i thought you was from
somewhere like another country
bosnia bosnia bosnia there we go they
never thought they would see the biggest
occurs near lincoln was the biggest
hockey philly this is the top i think
shout out to all the muslims worldwide
ramadan mubarak and i want to let all
the muslims know out there
ramadan is the best time of year let's
show the babies that
let's show the kids that shout out to uh
hijabifi
nah shout out to uh nick buck beanie
siegel
uh freeway j-rock big osama
everybody who volunteered and sponsored
our e toy drive it was so beautiful to
see
our babies get to have fun every year
they gotta watch all this christmas
uh stuff go on so it was just great to
be festive
you know decorate you know i got stuff
going on man i got
i got i got plates this year we got the
plates with the eve mubarak on it you
know we
we getting in the vibe and you should
get in the vibe too let's this is
beautiful we are the best of humanity we
are number one we are the most beautiful
we are the smartest
we are the strongest we we should be the
happiest let's show it
let's love each other man love your
neighbor for real for real
and um i'mma sign out like that may
allah have mercy on us all
and go to my instagram right now and get
you some merch and support everything
eddie is doing with the things show
yo i'll be honest with you bro i do
interviews every day well this was one
of the ones i was waiting to do
i love your show i love the way you guys
you know your producers and edit
everything up so it's not it's not hard
to make me look good but make me look
good
yeah man big big mpf man shout out to
the whole muslim dog
eddie some ice man you looking a little
yeah
earlier you mentioned the breakfast club
man we don't need the breakfast club and
we got the dean's show
and we got all these different muslim
platforms we building up our own
platforms
and i'm gonna play so you wanna say hi
it's not lean right here this is what i
was talking about when i said about
assalamu alaikum this was the one i was
like
this is the one i was praying for in
mashallah
i see you uh inshallah here in chicago
or in philly we'll be getting some of
those crab cakes
in charlotte i can't wait man and let me
know keep me posted with my show ready
so i can promote it to the world so i
can be the biggest one ever in show